hey guys I'm Ryan right time I'm sure ha
we're doing that because this is a video
inspired by Bruce Lee this video is
called my son five-year-old acting Bruce
Lee's nunchuck scene Shaku moon choco
scene damn blue [ __ ] damn haha little
[ __ ] crackheads of badass
ah
very impressive that's incredibly
impressive
I would be that kid when I grew up I
grew up in the martial arts world I've
seen a lot of little kids try martial
arts that was incredibly that's that I
would not want to fight that when we did
Taekwondo for a little bit we learned
nunchucks and I you know I got pretty
good at it that kid is significantly
better yeah I am yeah
do people ever actually fight with
nunchucks do they just kind of trade
moves back that tuxedo move is just like
them doing a thing like 20 feet from the
other guy well the thing is with
nunchucks there's a lot of techniques
that require you to hold it like that
like I gather yeah but that doesn't look
cool on camera it's like you do all that
shut like stuff you wave it around
everything and then it comes time to
actually fight you just hold them
together hit yeah exactly
in his lap down maneuvers he use with
the metal and stuff yeah I know that kid
had everything down and you didn't just
have cool moves he had the exact moves
any have the timing down let's cast him
in the reboot let's cast him in the
reboot of Game of Death let's do this
you could do a whole movie starring that
kid yeah and it would be believable Spy
Kids 5 you idiot others are spike its
par 3 yeah
4d oh yeah cuz I had smell-o-vision and
Jessica Alba don't she know movies sorry
I you know I don't know what I was
thinking I really liked the first fight
kids movie it was like I was a kid when
I came out
everyone knows Spy Kids 3ds the best
well yeah that was great stuff thanks
for telling me that was out I really
enjoyed that I do too if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
reel rejects you could check out Gerry's
playlist reasons to Jerry where he does
move your reviews in his vehicle he
drives around it's a lot of dangerous
stuff speeds hundred miles per hour
while he's reviewing I'm actually
getting a gig as a monster truck driver
some record my reviews while I'm like
crushing other codes that would be
pretty sweet and and you can follow us
on Facebook Instagram and Twitter where
if we get enough followers we get
product placement
you betcha coffee coffee dude coffee is
great for many things
reenergize is you it it is good for your
heart and you know if if you're tired
but your girlfriend really wants to [ __ ]
coffee Jesse James hey hoes what it
going hey how's it going
I watch your videos every day and they
make me fall on my ass laughing you are
my favorite Channel alright Jesse James
thanks a lot buddy don't sit down while
you watch ya instead of having to fall
you know what you should do if you want
like multiple pleasures you should set
up a dildo place it on your chair take
off your pants so when you're laughing
so hard that feels so good
then you fall and you sit on the dildo
and you get anal pleasure my friend why
would you do this advice from Ryan
writes during a video of a five year old
boy don't away numchucks